hay que hablar de un encuentro muy
importante para francia como fue la
reunión de 30 minutos entre el primer
ministro británico boris johnson y el
presidente manuel macrón recordemos las
tensiones que enfrentan a ambos países
en los últimos días por las cuotas
pesqueras que el reino unido no ha
entregado a los pescadores franceses eso
es en las aguas inglesas y también
obviamente la disputa más amplia de la
compra de los submarinos australianos y
la alianza august entre australia el
reino unido y eeuu obviamente de ese
encuentro básicamente que fue cordial el
presidente manuel macro me recordó a
boris johnson que debe cumplir las
normas concretamente del break city que
entrega obviamente esas licencias que
está pidiendo francia a ambos líderes
acordaron reunirse para bajar las
tensiones y evitar una escalada
recordemos que francia había puesto un
ultimátum para el próximo martes dijo
que iba a tomar medidas en lo que
respecta a la descarga de productos
marinos británicos en francia si el
reino unido no procedía a entregar esas
licencias y el otro es entre el
presidente de eeuu joe biden y su
homólogo turco erdogán que viene
precedidos de polémicas con respecto a
los derechos humanos turquía quería
expulsar a 10 embajadores occidentales
que pidieron la liberación de un
opositor turco eso no se produjo
obviamente el tema de los derechos
humanos estuvo en este encuentro así
como también la democracia va a ir donde
lo recordarán como es importante y le
recordó también que toma nota de la
adquisición de misiles de defensa ruso
adquiridos recientemente por ankara